Das russische sicherheitsunternehmen kaspersky
lab hat den wohl schrecklichsten trojaner für android geräte etwa aufgespürt eine software namens sky go free die schon seit
2014er unwesen treibt mit ihr lassen sich android geräte regelrecht fernsteuern wie gefährlich ist das programm wirklich werden auch deutsche user
ausspioniert und wie könnt ihr euch effektiv schützen
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle info herzlich willkommen bei klicks um science-fiction
Sky go free kann nicht nur whatsapp mit lesen sondern hat noch
47 weitere funktionen und die sind selbst für experten und expertinnen
mehr als erschreckend auf facebook und skype
beispielsweise sind nicht sicher und kann mit gelesen und kopiert werden und jetzt haltet euch fest sky go free kann sogar unbemerkt euer smartphone
mikrofon einschalten sowie die frontkamera für videos und bilder nutzen ja also ein wichtiger grund um sich einen
mechanischen schutz für die kamera zuzulegen und der hatte sich ja schon auch standort kalender sms und anrufe listen werden ausspioniert
in einigen fällen müssen die opfer zunächst
berechtigungen erteilen damit die spionage funktionen
greifen und der trojaner die gewünschte informationen bekommt dort kaspersky kann sky go free auf huawei geräten beispielsweise
sogar noch nach dem ausschalten
weiterlaufen mit recht fragt euch jetzt sicher ob wir auch betroffen seid achtgeben muss man tatsächlich auf websites die so aussehen wie die bekannte
mobilfunkanbieter auf diesen extra präparierten seiten wird man aufgefordert das smartphone zu aktualisieren bzw neu zu konfigurieren
dabei installiert sich sky go free auf dem gerät an den benutzer geht dann eine willkommens nachricht wie diese raus
sehr geehrter kunde wir aktualisieren ihre konfiguration und sie wird so bald wie möglich
fertig sagt wie das ganze im detail abläuft ist aber noch nicht raus jedenfalls zeigt das alles mal wieder auf ein neues erst einmal nachdenken
bevor man auf unbekannte links in mails klickt oder dubiose daten anhänge geöffnet oder wenn sich eine webseite öffnet einfach
bestätigen
denn auch ein wenig entwarnung gibt es bislang wurde es nur auf android geräten entdeckt aber auch windows phone sind wohl nicht ganz
sicher darauf deuten code schnipsel in einigen modulen hin die das sicherheits forschungsteam von
kaspersky aufgespürt hatte kleine bemerkung am rande wenn ihr es nicht schon längst organisiert euch eine vernünftige antiviren software für euer smartphone
bislang ist der trojaner allerdings nur in italien aufgetaucht hier wurde obwohl entwickelt wahrscheinlich von einem italienischen unternehmen
das unter anderem auch an staatlichen
überwachungslösungen arbeitet im klartext könnte es sich also um einen staatstrojaner handeln mit dem der staat die möglichkeit
bekommt mehr oder weniger verdächtige personen zu überwachen ist reiki ist nur ein einzelfall wenn auch ein ziemlich perfide
welche viren und trojaner und so weiter kennt ihr die wirklich so ein ausmaß an schreibt es in die kommentare
dann machen wir ein special dazu übrigens könnt ihr jetzt auch mitglied bei klicks um hier auf youtube werden das seht ihr unter dem video
mit einigen vorteilen und es werden mehr wenn ihr kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollte dann hättet mich bei whatsapp
dann umgeht er die etwas unzuverlässige abend box hier auf youtube und die verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich
von jedem upload und zwar noch vor allen anderen technik garantieren einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks und social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber
nicht die genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter dafür auch draufklicken computer werden 1000 mal schneller
bis dann bleibt dran und ansonsten das pfeifen ist beim nächsten oder übernächsten mal den weg